i have unintentionally been
towards my partner where are you going
to preach
because this is your domain you're the
expert so i picked this one for you
you're stupid
i definitely
so
it used to be in my vocabulary where i
would say the n word with
the a i would wrap it i would i would do
just those things but um my slang in
general would just take her off and then
i became conscious of it and i really
liked her or i still do of course i love
you um
i started changing the way i speak i
feel like she should be over here too
um
she would do uh asian accents
i appreciate the fact that he aired out
i [ __ ] up but [ __ ] you done [ __ ] up
you should be here too let's hold hands
you can't use the word [ __ ] ching chong
chang chong
that's what happened that's what
happened you can't like fried chicken
like that
i don't know i don't know what that was
what yeah
you can't use that word but would you
like a glass of water
you can't you know you're mexican you're
not black stop saying the n word one two
three five six seven two three
i don't even know what the [ __ ] what
that was i don't know it's just funny to
me let's throw everything out there i've
definitely been uh
ignorant so we were
so we
had we had an argument and i was upset
and i had previously expressed how the
the stereotype or the stigma on angry
black men or angry black women and how
that
makes me feel and so we got into an
argument
i was an angry black man
but in that moment of anger he actually
called me an angry black man which which
is like the worst thing amazing is
crazy because
what
i'm not a fighter
i don't get into fights no i don't get
into
verbal match i don't do that i don't
scream at you
i don't um
for her to have called me that
it would have been a rap
really
angry black man that had been a rap
i don't know i don't even know i'd have
to ask myself that i have to ponder on
that but it would have been a wrap i'd
be like i
really like if yes even if
i go out like let's say i go out with a
black woman
right
i'm with her
and we have an argument and she calls
the cops on me
interesting you know the relationship we
have with cops
you call the cops on me when i know
there was no reason and then you called
the cops
wow there's no coming back from that if
there was a reason for me to do that
which i really thought it would happen
but if there was a reason for her to
call the cop a good reason then i need
to get out out there i need to i need to
check myself i need to do something
because that we got a bigger problem we
got a bigger problem because our
relationship
brought that part of me which is to what
i understand non-existent but if you
didn't there was no reason for you to
call the cops and you called them and
you called them i can't go back from
that okay i can sex gets steamy since
you are interracial
whoever wrote that as a goofball what
unless you're into race play i don't
know why you would care
if i was just at the race but i could
understand
but sometimes
you know because playing a slave master
scenario doesn't seem as fun
people or if you're fetching but if i
got a white girl who's a blonde hair
blue eyes and she's like and you're into
that stuff
yeah yeah there's not many uh sexual
stereotypes about white men
but like walking down the street
especially um dating an asian woman like
i get looks from men all the time being
like you know white guys are just like
that fashion
[Music]
yeah definitely i could see that
i could definitely see that
when he goes back home and he's like for
christmas or whatever and he has his
uncle coming to him and he's like so you
know it's just gonna be
sushi if it's between two consenting
adults the freak stuff in the bedroom if
race sprinkles is is put into that
context
what do we think of that like it's just
in the bedroom or is it like possible to
just keep it in the bedroom how would
how would race be
put into the bedroom use your
imagination
yeah yeah bro
yeah bro
hey hey hey you don't
yeah that's not my auntie if you don't
know i don't know what the hell is dude
name is it was a senator
yeah
swerve i meant to use the n-word
how do you hey you figure it out
you gonna do your homework you got
google you got a smartphone you figure
it out don't
put me into this let me just tell you
guys let me just tell you guys it's out
there oh it's out there it's out there
not hard to find yuck yuck y'all can
google race play um
i sometimes feel like i betrayed my own
race
three
two
one
go
the black guys went whoa yeah
someone betrayed his own race what do
you think
you [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
they should i don't feel like i betrayed
them but they sure they should try to
make me feel like that because that
people sure try to make me feel like
that i understand where it's from i
understand i understand the sentiment so
it used to get it used to bother me it
really used to bother me and [ __ ] but i
got nothing to prove to nobody but i
understand what a sentiment is for some
reason that i don't for the same reason
like i told you that i i don't whenever
like i walk down new york wherever the
[ __ ] i am when
whether it's new york or uh florida if i
hear comments from black lady i don't
say [ __ ] no cause i know what i heard
it's from they're wrong
they're making assumptions like the same
way they don't want us to make
assumptions about them but that's beyond
that because the hurt is first you know
i mean so i understand that but i don't
say [ __ ] because i know where it's from
but yeah i don't feel like i did me
personally i only um the train round
race behind closed doors yes yeah out in
public
never nubian queen that's right behind
closed doors
nestle white chocolate
do you know
do you
know
how many times i've gotten angry white
women message me after i said that yeah
yeah yeah i know just jokingly i don't
know but they get so upset how dare you
not want to show me in part read the
messages [ __ ] i don't know you i don't
even know you why are you so pressed
you're seeing messages from girls that
you're not even with and you've never
met as if you guys are dating your
[ __ ] out there doing the most
and if you are a white girl that i have
dealt with just shh
okay
well right now me and the nubian queens
we're out in public okay
i definitely feel like that man i feel
like
especially where i'm from
i
did my people a disservice by playing
into that stereotype and knowing what i
stand for now
it's hard for me to feel like i'm going
to be taken serious in the future if i
ever want to speak on controversial
topics my people won't respect what i
say because like it doesn't add up my
views and stuff and then i just i'm
dating somebody
outside of my race behind the scenes i
feel like i lose respect in a way
then you shut the [ __ ] up about it and
you keep it moving that's it
just keep it moving it's a fact you will
never be a true
pro black you can that card has been
revoked
it's okay i don't i just stand there
can't be for the black cause and lay
with the white devil that's what they
say yes
i'm just like man sure whatever do you
don't shut the [ __ ] up about it then
even if you had the possibility to help
do you feel like you're doing a
disservice shut the [ __ ] up about it
stop for you to be there sometimes you
have to know your place to know your
role and shut the [ __ ] up one of my
favorite sentences shut the [ __ ] up
it serves in many many many ways that's
right shut up
if you lay with the cockazoids my
brother
understand that you are not for your
brothers
i have a mighty zulu king
the third the role of every great master
is to conquer the women of other races
as you create more conquests
it was very natural for kings of nubian
descent to take on the women that he
pillaged and rumbled through
hold that [ __ ]
i may enjoy them for the night
but i will always be loyal to the night
the darkness
if you don't think your [ __ ] out of here
man get the [ __ ] out of here
we know what the ancient egyptians were
you know what they never did
slacked off
as they reproduce with their own people
we don't mix and match this isn't
build-a-bear they want to talk about
mixed babies i prefer the term
abomination
[ __ ] you look like a mixed baby bam man
my forehead is no it's never
i didn't say it wasn't from that corner
but i'm just like it's a multiple
variants of big forces
you got a genetics for real for real on
that okay so like i get comments
literally my dm's been like oh alex
you're not with us no more right and i'm
like
do you want me or do you not want me you
know i it doesn't bother me if you don't
want me and i understand it is what it
is they do want you it's just not her
yeah they want they don't want you
without her it's like when you organize
a party and you bring a plus one that
nobody else wants to see at the party
that's what your girl is today you know
but you can join if you get rid of her
you're allowed into the party yeah
definitely exactly it's like it's like
going to party with amanda seals you're
not getting it smoking cannabis doesn't
have to hurt freeze pipes making a
unique line of freezable pipes bubblers
bones dab breaks and more if you can
smoke from it freeze pipe makes it
the secret is freezable glycerin
chambers that cools smoke by hundreds of
degrees for smoother and bigger hits
when smoke passes through these frozen
chambers
lift off it's instantly cooled for a
much nicer hit you'll feel instantly
your throat and lungs will thank you
recyclers are commonly used for dabbing
but freeze pipe builds this for both
insanely smooth and cold hits
go to the freezepipe.com
to get yours today use code aba that's
abba and save 15
off your first order i have always
wanted mixed babies
three
two
one
go
at one point in my life i kind of wanted
to have mixed babies with almost every
race
yeah you know what i'm gonna shout i'm
out and i'm gonna say thank you okay i'm
gonna say thank you because you're being
honest i think a lot more people
actually want these things but they're
saying the politically correct modern
answers true but trust me out there
you're in a relationship like this
all the time people like oh you guys
have such cute babies and all people
always saying that
don't know if that's so
but i just wanted i'm real into genetics
i would like to see um
how my kids would turn out
and
i've never heard that sense i'm really
into genetics and i want to see how my
kids are going
it's a it's a hobby that i have
you know genetics i like to see
how things are getting mixed up oh look
at this specimen the mixture of
afro-brazilian with afro-peruvian has
come out quite well ah turns out that
japanese and taiwanese don't mix
russians and arabs
what disgusting children as a mixed-race
person myself you don't have a group of
people to really be around i mean
sometimes you connect with one side
sometimes you connect with another side
but for me it sucked actually a lot why
does he look like he's part of bone
thugs in harmony
i'm just waiting for going
tell me what you're gonna
[Music]
this isn't build a bear this is real
life
and in my mind i wanted to have kids
that was exactly my skin tone or very
close to it and look like me because i
am conceited as well
where the hell i'm going to find
somebody to do that
and it work out and they're just a
perfect wife i don't i don't believe in
that anymore it's funny because that was
actually something we talked about when
we first started dating that became a
insecurity of mine i was like so why are
we dating because i cannot provide
absolutely any of that for you and so i
i understand like i said why he feels
that way why a lot of the black
community feels that way um so i'm just
glad that i'm accepted now
i'm just glad that you gave up
because that was his word she's like
i've just given up on that and i'm with
this white girl
he's like i'm just glad that you know
you chose
that i'm accepted now that's not what he
said
but hey i'm glad that you took it that
way that's a positive spin
being linked to another race has its
benefits
three
two
one
go
preach you can speak on this no i can't
isn't there a benefit to having
a white partner for certain scenarios
not that i see it what about when you're
applying for apartments
i don't have to i have my white
privilege what do you mean my parents
owned apartments i never had to apply
for a party but you could imagine those
scenarios right i could imagine yeah
yeah you know so i sent my girlfriend
and everything and stuff and then i show
up a moving day yeah [ __ ] for you to
move her no [ __ ]
i'm here
yeah yeah i could definitely see your
advantage yeah definitely i could see
that but to me it could also be a
disadvantage of myself definitely yeah
you know but i've seen the dude who was
riding with his girlfriend and a cop
stopped him he's like is he kidnapping
yeah definitely but we crossed the
border that's that once they they
treated her like i was taking her
hostage or something yeah that happened
when the cops stop whenever when i'm in
with
my car with any
white people
there's issues yeah there's issues yeah
cops pull over and we're like yeah you
safe ma'am
are you okay
they want to speak to the passenger i'm
like yeah i need to speak to her
it's my [ __ ] and then i end up in cuffs
it's my [ __ ] okay do you ever feel like
being with a white person like could
shield you from
like discrimination or like that they
could like stand up for you in a certain
context like if you were in like an
altercation with the police or something
like wood having a white person there
like sure right in that sense you said
no
well not one for the cop thing yeah my
girl just i just it draws more attention
it's good because
she's there and she witnesses it right
and then she can talk about she can talk
she can talk about it about
she can talk about it to her family that
are not experiencing that because
they're not around and around like the
city city and pub i mean there is
they're not in the car with a black
person they may not know they may not
see that interaction exactly so whenever
they see the news and stuff like that
they
ask questions yeah and when i talk about
i talk to them they're like oh word and
then my girl goes in and she's like
no it'd be like that it's not just him
being
it was really nothing to do you know
what's funny is remember i did that
comedy showing that woman was saying all
that foul stuff i did a youtube video on
it right yeah
there was a couple white comedians there
and they're like oh i've never seen that
before yeah of course not the immigrants
like the arab guy who was with me she
was just happy he was like yeah i saw it
too yeah yeah we were just like yeah
yeah we all heard it because we all
heard it
we know we know what she was about but
for those guys they never heard
something
exactly just screamed a bunch of eggs
exactly so i was just clapping because i
was like y'all see what i see right i'm
not crazy it's not in my head and
sometimes you argue with people with
white people and they like it doesn't
exist it doesn't exist because they
never seen it yeah but it do happen it's
funny that we're we're really happy that
it happens
when it happens like yes it's like not
that we're happy that it happens just
like we could we could yes we could put
our finger on it it's not
interpretation it's not no it's kind of
like that it was clear it's kind of like
when someone believes in ufos and
there's proof you get excited because
you're no longer just seen as a crazy
all right so what are your closing
thoughts in regards to the video in
general not really in fightful it was
what it was was really unsurfaced that's
true belief for you
but yeah it is what it is i mean it's a
thing
if it is going to be able to
open the the discussion about different
[ __ ]
sure
it opens your eyes on different things
so it about opens your eye on you know
it's a thing out there people have
different um
views and opinion about this [ __ ] it's
just funny to watch other than that i
mean
interracial relationship
people always try to be righteous with
it but you know i feel like i can talk
into issues
you don't have to always talk you know
well i guess we can kind of bring it up
because you made some good points before
but i said to you before that i felt
like um interrelational relationships
are more difficult today than they were
let's say 20 years ago no it wasn't
i'm just gonna finish my thought i did
exactly what i did last time i know but
can i finish my thought
please sure but i'm already because you
were rude last time so can i finish
myself
i'm i'm rude now
that's stupid
finish your thoughts
and the reason why i said that was good
early 2000s uh for me my experience with
interracial dating was kind of easy and
seamless uh for the year that i was
dating somebody of a different race
otherwise i felt like if i were to do
the same thing today it would be a lot
more difficult no it's not it's early
two thousands first of all
cisco got an album all the fathers were
dancing to the tongue thought song that
was a black man so they learned to
appreciate hip-hop and stuff okay before
that they didn't know about that then
but didn't know about the
you know all they knew about it was big
butts and they couldn't lie and there
was lying
you know what i mean that was [ __ ] up
back then it was [ __ ] there was never
been it was worse than that it's worse
now no it's not
it's worse
it was worse back then you couldn't walk
the street holding hands with your girl
you would get beat throwing some [ __ ] at
you you think i was able to walk the
streets of new york manhattan without no
comments
even my i'm not even talking about the
bronx i'm not talking about uh cambria
heights queens i ain't talking about yo
yo listen me and my cousin before we're
in cambria ice queens i was talking
about my cousins in the 80s and just
because i was talking french people was
was like yo shut up they don't like
french people
they would hate bruh they would hate you
because you're haitian don't don't try
to date a white girl
bring it up nah boo
now
[ __ ] you mean it's not gonna happen
they wouldn't let it pass they wouldn't
let it pass
yo they'll throw [ __ ] at mm-hmm mm-hmm
it's easier now you're gonna compare it
now
like you would show up to the doors of a
girl you don't even know if you have to
throw down with the father or the sons
gunshots and everything
[ __ ]
it's easier now no what's so bad about
now well i think
people often take their cues from social
media it's how people really allow the
information so a lot of stuff that
you'll ordinarily be able to keep
private or would are very public
nowadays and people know they know
because you open your mouth
yeah but here's the truth
people want to open their mouths they
want to be able to share the truth about
their relationship sure and if they do
they get all that backlash that's where
people are but that backlash back then
was real not be on a screen you could
shut that [ __ ] off yo listen i had to
fight people because they were like some
of my friends were walking down with
their girlfriend on their boyfriend they
got beat by a hoe skinny head the girl
too
this is not pg no really the girl got
everybody got punishment let's put it
that way and then we got we gotta we
gotta retaliate because of that
or cousins that yo no don't be no b it
was bad back then it was gonna get now a
couple of comments and then you're gonna
feel bad for there too take a glass of
water drink it hope it's not the sunny
and keep it moving
keep it moving back then it was
you getting the physical fights
just for walking with that girl
it was bad back then yeah it's a little
bit more violence now but it's nothing
like back then especially walk-in shoes
you think i would have brought my girl
to church in the 90s
the comments and [ __ ]
you your real live comments next thing
you know the pastor is making a sermon
about you and your girl
nah b
it was worse back then okay
you good i'm super good i defer to you
yeah i understand but that's the
stupidest thing you said today and you
said some pretty stupid [ __ ] but it's
important it's important to play devil's
advocate it's important to come some hot
takes sure the hot ticks can be done you
know because
you know what i'm saying but but that's
why i brought the question to you why i
imagine you're a veteran absolutely 20
years in the game interracial warrior
okay
interracial veteran all right you guys
love your veterans get a poppy seed make
it half black half white right for him
okay
show this man
[Laughter]
get the [ __ ] you don't like that that's
a pretty good one
i know you yeah
you know i mean you gotta be quick on
the feet all right because if you're not
walking running away from her white dad
sometimes yeah i mean you gotta be run
away from other things but listen i
think when it comes to racial dangers
they have their own issues their own
set of problems
but hey you know like preach says he
didn't fall in love with a white woman
she fell in love with a girl that
happens to be white
that's the best that's one of the best
bars you ever said
it's such a good bar cause i'm not i'm
not with her because she's white but you
also know some [ __ ] who fell in love
with a white woman yo bro i know i know
i know
i'm just saying that's one of your best
bars you know that's that's a bar that
you said that i never forgot
why because i use it
give me your phone if you throw that
[ __ ] again
this one
it's an iphone this [ __ ]
you stupid
but there's definitely some dudes
because i use it no man but there's
definitely there's definitely dudes who
do fall in love with
asian women not only who happens to be
asian but asian women yeah yeah yeah
that fetish said this [ __ ] it's always a
[ __ ] in my inbox like uh why is
that so bad just the [ __ ] up
do whatever you want but i think there's
a giant difference between the two just
me
but everyone's entitled to that you want
to do that do that live your best life
but anyways that's a whole other
discussion we want to know what you guys
think in the comments below let us know
what you think about interracial dating
preach being a veteran all that good
do you use it
[Music]
is
foreign
[Music]
be